another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the scp foundation yes forum  trolls are annoying no they don't  automatically become d-class personnel  dr bright personally we think that  someone who's lived as long as you and  died multiple times would have thicker  skin but your repeated insistence to  turn formites like booty hunter 69 and  danky danky literature club 420 nice  into d-class personnel is as bizarre and  sad as they are nonsensical people need  to be truly despicable to warrant having  a place among the ranks of d-class  personnel they need to be truly  monstrous evil underhanded unethical  bottom of the barrel individuals and  frankly form trolls do not fit the bill  youtube commenters on the other hand